16 and 19 as they face marcus stroman a
guy they've seen plenty of before yeah
and he's faced the orioles plenty times
before as you've seen the toyota numbers
this season since 2017 he's three and
two with a 1.06 bra against the o's lead
off single and it'll bring up austin
hayes the right fielder
[Applause]
two strike pitch bounced off the glove
of vr into left field hustling into
third cedric mullins and the orioles
have him on the corner
with nobody down
i think that would probably be the
reason
little dribbler strumming off the mat
has a play at the plate and now mccann
has mullins in a rundown
and makes the toss to vr they make the
tag for the out and the runners are at
first and second well handled by both
stroman and mccann to make sure the
other runners couldn't move up and
that's the first out of the night
two men away
orioles now with runners at first and
second and friendy galvest the shortstop
and former philadelphia philly will be
the batter want to know the count now
the pitch swinging a ground ball to
first nice pick by alonso with his shoe
tops behind the bag takes it there
himself side retired good job by marcus
strowman and one of the great starts in
major league history from john means 27
batters faced in a no-hitter the only
person who reached sam hagerty on a drop
third strike he was the only no-hitter
of its kind in major league history and
john means will try to chase johnny
vandermeer tonight jeff mcneal steps in
lefty against lefty they just the bench
of the orioles just told that they want
lindor in the batting circle in the
warm-up circle he said he's too close to
the batter and flynn doors
yelling at them now you gotta be kidding
yeah they are the first time i've seen
that guy stand there all the time and
keith always moans about it but nobody
ever does anything that's lined in left
center field there'll be no no hitter
tonight
for john means
now with two away pete alonzo will be
the batter
and delivers and this ball is hit in the
air center field mullins jogs in
looks skyward makes the catch
and so alonso's homeless drought
continues and means lousy hit but puts a
zero on the scoreboard jeff mcneal the
banner now against the lefty means
and that's up the middle and mcneil's
got the mets second hit mullins quickly
over to track it down mcneil's going to
test him and he's going to be out by a
million miles
that is a terrible decision by mcmillan
did he hurt himself halfway there
because he he pulled up like he heard a
hammy or something as soon as he made
the turn and tried to turn it on
yeah something happened there gary well
jeff mcneal is leaving the game after
appearing to hurt himself trying to
stretch a single into a double jose
perazza has replaced him at second base
chops this one down to third vr comes in
to get it
three ground ball outs for strowman in
that fourth inning that's what the
doctor ordered
and there's one away as conforto will
back
breaking ball hit hard
austin hayes on the move with a nice
running catch
two down
he breaks his back and he rolls it
through the infield well means got that
ball to the inside corner but pete
strong enough to fight it off and get it
through the vacant space in the infield
for a two-out hit
so back-to-back two odd hits by alonso
and pilar and the mets have runners at
the corner
and now jonathan vr will try and get him
in with two out
the shake of the glove and means
delivers
pop-up second base rio ruiz handles that
and the mets are down in the fourth they
strand two
and john means
again has been good at getting ahead
which he's been doing all year
and has been able to put some quick
innings together he'll start off with
mccann in the last of the fifth one two
on the way
that's strike three
james mccann down looking first out here
in the mets fifth and almora is coming
up to the plate
2-2
swing and a miss now more expanded means
got him on the change up so back-to-back
strikeouts for means had only 1k through
four has two to start the fifth
marcus stroman through 72 pitches in the
first five innings john means threw only
59.
trey mancini after the third time hit
into a fielder's choice and struck out
on the outside corner and mancini's
caught looking at a fastball
five strikeouts now for marcus
but a break for the mets now they've got
runners at the corners one out they've
got that runner on third 90 feet away
the first run of the game and pete
alonso coming up
one strike to the mets cleanup hitter
popped up
mancini calls makes the catch big out
there means needs only one more out to
keep this a nothing nothing game pilar
does have a single and two times up
fly ball center field mullins calling
he's there makes the catch and john mean
pitches out of a sticky situation
severino is going to be walked
intentionally to force brandon hyde's
hand you've got john means who's thrown
15 straight scoreless innings and has
only thrown 74 pitches tonight and
they're going to call him back and bat
for him
with a chance to take the lead in six
strong innings after a no-hitter by john
means
that's going to be all for strowman luis
rojas is coming out so both managers
pulling their starters at the same time
here in the seventh stroman will take
his exit
and luke will come on to replace him
let's not leave it happily but when the
mets made the pitching change he
counters with a right-hand bat in pat
valenka
first pitch swinging fly ball
deep right field that's going to get it
in
conforto makes a good catch on the track
galvez comes in to score and vallejka
jumps on the first pitch john means
smiling orioles ahead one nothing
austin hayes flies one to center will
hit back goes el mora warning track and
he made the catch then he dropped it as
he smacked the wall face-first he's hurt
hayes is on his way to third and he's in
standing with a triple and now the
concern for albert almoro who hit that
padding on the center field fence as
hard as you can hit it face first he had
the ball in his glove when he hit the
ball came out and he is
rocked
spinal or neck injury
but up on his feet so clearly there's no
concern about that
but obviously concussion then is the
next
most important thing to check for
guys one positive sign is as albert el
mora was walking off the
field he motioned to the fans and said
i'm all right i'm all right so you know
positive sign for sure as he was walking
the field off the field
drops down a bunt it's a good one
throw from third not in time and it's an
rbi bunt base hit for freddie galvez
what a beauty
hayes scores and the orioles go on top
two nothing
don't two walks in the inning one
allowed by pleco now won by scott
and the mets have an engraved invitation
trailing two to nothing but now conforto
will be the go ahead man at the plate
and four lines one to center field for a
base hit neato to third he'll be waved
around the mets are on the board
michael conforto with an rbi single and
it's two to one
[Applause]
that's a solo home run away from tying
this game kevin pollard right and better
the the 1-0 and there's one that's hit
in the air to deep left field down the
line it might go it's hooking it is a
home run home run for pillar and the
mets have tied the game you're gonna
undoubtedly take another look at this
and it is
and this is gonna be overturned they
don't even go to replay
eighth pitch of the back coming to
pillar and he pulls one down a third and
scoots on viralways and pilar gets
aboard
one man out
and now dom smith who's got home run
power valdez ready the pitch hit high in
the air to right center field hustling
over is hayes he dives he can't get it
the runners held up now here comes polar
around third the relay throw to the
plate not in time he slides in safely
the throw gets away backed up by valdez
his throw to third not in time vr is at
third on at first dom smith he's got an
rbi single that ties the game and the
winning run is 90 feet away with one man
out can mazeka get vr in from third to
two and the zika grounds went down to
first coming home as mancini the slide
save for the mets win it but zika does
it again
he drives home another winning run the
mets rally for two in the bottom of the
knife and they beat the orioles three to
two
the king of the walk off fielder's
choice patrick mazeka loses another
uniform top